ooh bear streets right there but down in
new orleans mardi gras
arrives just three days from now while
fat tuesday seems to get all the
attention
it's actually just the final celebration
following weeks and weeks of parades and
other events
the pandemics put much of that on hold
but the ever
creative residents of the city have
found a whole new canvas for their
artistic expression
our jamie wax has their story
for the people of new orleans mardi gras
is more than just the world's biggest
free party
it's the throbbing wholesome
eating heart of the city's culture
but how do you keep mardi gras alive
when a pandemic has stopped the parades
from
rolling you turn it into
yardy graw all across the city
and beyond house floats have been
popping up
the universe put me in the right place
at the right time and
everybody just latched on to the idea
and here we are
you know 3000 house floats later back in
late november new orleans resident megan
boudreau
tweeted it's decided we're doing this
turn your house into a float and throw
all the beads from your attic at your
neighbors walking by
that bit of levity and that simple idea
spiraled into a grassroots movement that
transformed new orleans homes
into the famed floats that typically
parade through the city
i got on facebook and made a group to
you know try and recruit some people and
that group
just exponentially grew within
days into something that was clearly
going to need to be organized and not
just
the low-key neighborhood thing that i
had intended
she now has a team of over 50 volunteers
and has inspired multiple other crews
and individuals to join her in creating
something to celebrate
it's just been such a long year and
everything seems to be bad news
and just from day one everyone i talked
to said this is so great i have
something
fun to do something positive to think
about and i think that's really why
everybody just
clung to it so quickly because i don't
know that it would happen in any other
year
it's a real triumph triumph of art
triumph of
you know spirit it's wonderful doug
mccash has been covering new orleans
culture for local publications for
decades
and has been photographing some of the
most creative floats as they appear
throughout the city
as you have documented all of these
places you've encountered a lot of
locals a lot of tourists passing by
families what are you hearing from the
people around
these house floats i think people are
really
celebrating that we're supposed to have
this reputation
for being creative and never say die
you know that kind of thing and this is
such a great example of it and i think
everybody is really enjoying that
even in covet we're living up to
expectations
a sentiment echoed by joni broussard we
caught up with the louisiana native as
she was
out with her family what does it mean
when the parades are not rolling
for you to be able to see these houses
like this well
this is actually incredible you get to
walk and actually see and take your time
as when floats pass
you know it's kind of you gotta watch it
or you miss it so this is this is pretty
neat
so for you this is not like the second
choice this is even better
i think so i mean covet has done a lot
of
bad you know for a lot of people but i
don't think people would have thought of
this if kobe wouldn't happen
city council member jay banks is
chairman of the board of the zulu social
aid and pleasure club
an iconic part of mardi gras parading
it is new orleans culture we are the
melting pot of the world the cultures
here all blended
from french to spanish to african they
all came here together and made this
magic that we see today
and we have this wonderful gift to share
this is absolutely magical
and this is not the first time that
magic and this city's resilience
have been tested the first casualty of
katrina was normal
we knew when the storm hit normal died
first so we needed to come back and we
led the way back home
with that first mardi gras after katrina
that was a much smaller parade there
were far fewer people but it sent a
message that hey new orleans is still
here
something the people of new orleans
prove time
and time again this is not um what we
had hoped for or planned but the reality
of it is again
it can cancel the way we practice our
customs but it can't cancel
our customs it'll just be different than
what it's been in the past so no
mardi gras is not dead it's just
different
for cbs this morning saturday jamie wax
new orleans and this is the only second
time
that the mardi gras parades have been
canceled the first was due to a police
strike and full disclosure
by my father-in-law so okay but what's
interesting about this is that new
orleans
always as they said always comes back
because they have so much to show
and so much to shine through resilient
resilient